ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
เพราะด้วยเองค่าพบกับครูหญิงแล้วก็ครูเอ๋
นะคะในวีดีโอระดับดีกินน่อ 1  1
ใส่ค่ะผู้หญิงจะถามอะไรครูเอ๋คะรู้เห็น
สถานหญิงดีกว่าค่ะได้ค่ะผู้หญิงมองเห็น
ไหมคะมองไม่เห็นค่ะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้
วันเสาร์ค่ะวันเสาร์อาหาร
วันเสาร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
28 ค่ะวันที่
เดือนอะไรคะอ่ะเสือเดือนพฤษภาคมค่ะเดือน
พฤษภาคมปีพต
อะไรคะตีผช
2565 ค่ะ
2565 ปีคศอะไรคะดีคอ
2022 ค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้
เวลา
15:00 น
20 น
3:00 น
20 นาทีนใช่ค่ะ
โอเคค่ะวันนี้วันเสาร์พ่อรักแล้วแล้วก็
โอเควันนี้ครูเอ๋เอ๋ก็มีมีการ sketch อีก
นะคะก็
มีมีอะไรอ่ะมีคำถามเหรอคะมีคำถามนิดหน่อย
อ่า
มีครับผู้หญิงเห็นไหมคะเห็นค่ะครูเอกลบ
อันนั้นออกก็ได้นะคะซ้อแหม่ม x ราวอ๋อ
[เพลง]
ตลอดเลย
ผู้หญิง
i สีแดงๆคะครูเอ๋
สีแดงๆเนี่ยเราเรียกว่า
Go  Man นะคะ
โกแมนแตะผู้หญิงกูไอ้ผู้หญิงอย่าเพิ่งถาม
สี
หรอตัวเองให้ได้ตัวเอกจะฝนพูดก่อนเดือน
ที่ 1 เนี่ยเดือนที่เฮาผู้หญิงก็นึกว่า
ครูเอ๋ให้ดูยังๆยังไม่ให้ยังไม่ให้ดูแต่
ไม่ให้ดูเดือนบทที่ 1 เนี่ยเดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนที่ 1 เดือนมกราคมค่ะเดือน
มกราคมราคะอะคุยเขียนแค่นี้เนาะเดือนราคม
เนี่ยนะคะเดือนที่ 1 ที่นี่วันนี้ที่เรา
จะคุยกันนะคะเกี่ยวกับเดือนเดือนทั้งหมด
เนี่ย 12 เดือนนะคะเดือนเนี่ยเห็นลบตรง
นี้ก่อนนะคะเนี่ยต้องลบ
ได้ค่ะหนูจะได้เขียนได้มาย
เดือนมีทั้งหมดนะคะ
สักครู่นะคะ
เลือกปากกาไม่ได้เดือนอ่ะมี
[เพลง]
1-12 นะค่ะถึง 12 ก็ 12 เดือน
12 เดือนเนี่ยเท่ากับตัว
เท่าไหร่คะผู้หญิง 1 ปี
1 ปีนะคะอ่ะ 12 เดือนเท่ากับ 1 ปี 1 ปี
เท่ากับกี่เดือนคะ 1 ปี =  12 เดือนค่ะ
แล้วก็เลยเข้าการเท่ากัน 1 ปีเท่ากับกี่
สัปดาห์คะ 1 ปี =
52 สัปดาห์ค่ะอ่อนักเรียนก็เขียนตรงนี้
เนาะหา
สัปดาห์นะคะ 1 ปี =  52 สัปดาห์แปลวันนี้
เรายังไม่พูดถึงสัปดาห์
อ้าวเราไม่พูดถึงปี
และเราจะพูดเรื่องเดือนโทรโหได้ค่ะเดือน
นี้นะคะเดือนนะ 1 ปีมี 12 เดือนแต่วันนี้
เป็นเดือนกับผู้หญิงโอ๋โอ๋ผู้ชายล่ะนัก
เรียนผู้ชายแบบอ้าวผู้ชายก็โอเคแบบผู้ชาย
อาจจะไม่ชอบ
โอ้โหผู้หญิงเนี่ยชอบมากกว่าคิดว่า 80%
ไหม
ใช่ค่ะ 80 ชายใช่ซื้อ
ของผู้หญิงชอบชาย
99 เปอร์เซ็นต์
99 เปอร์เซ็นต์นะคะครูเอ๋ไม่รู้ผู้หญิง
บางคนไม่ชอบ
บางคนก็อาจจะอาจจะผู้หญิง 80% ชอบค่ะ 99
เปอร์เซ็นต์ชอบครูเอ๋ไม่รู้แต่ผู้ชายอ่ะ
เด็กผู้ชายก็มีผู้ชายนิดหน่อยนะชอบผู้ชาย
ต้องซื้อให้ผู้หญิงใส่ค่ะก็เลยผู้ชายก็
เลยไม่ชอบผู้ชายก็เลยอาจจะแปร
อุ้ยมันเป็นเรื่องอะไรนะอะไรนะเมื่อกี้
เห็นแล้วนะผู้ชายผู้ชายเนี่ย
คิดอาหารไม่ชอบผู้หญิงน่ะหนู
ชอบตาไก่ค่ะผู้ชายไม่ชอบ
เดือนใช่ไหมเดือนแล้วก็ผู้หญิงอะไร
นั่นน่ะสิไปเลยค่ะเมื่อกี้ดูแล้วเดือนรา
คมนะคะถาดราคมนะคะอ่ะอ่าก็บอกว่าเวลาที่
เราใช่ไหมคะคุณวันเวลาที่เราเกิด
ค่ะ
อันนี้แม่แล้วนี่ผู้หญิงที่นี่ค่ะคุณแม่
ท้อง
คุณแม่ท้องแล้วคุณแม่ก็อะไรคะ
รอน
คลอดไม่ใช่ไม่ซ้ำกันคลอดมีออกทางหน้าคลอด
ข้อที่คุณแม่ร้องเสียงยังไงก็โอ้ยโอ้ย
เจ็บ
โอนเมื่อไหร่หญิงจะออกมาซะทีอีหญิงออกมา
ได้แล้ว
เราก็
อุด
หิวข้าวหิวข้าวออกมาก็กินเลยนะกูหญิง
ผู้หญิงเวลาคลอดผู้หญิงเกิดเดือนอะไรนาย
หญิงเกิน 12 เดือนเนี่ย 1  2  3  4  5
ที่ 7  8  9  10  11  12
ผู้หญิงเกิดเดือนที่ 3 ค่ะครูเอ๋ผู้หญิง
ไม่เดือนที่ 3 ราคาเดือน 3 นเกิดมาเดือน
ที่ 3 นะค่ะแล้วมีนาคมใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะ
เดือนที่ 3 เดือนมีนาคม
5 ค่ะแล้วครูเอ๋ล่ะคะคุณเอกเกิดไหมคะ
เกิดเกิดเกิดคนเค้กเกิดเดือนอะไรเดือนอะ
เกิดเดือนที่เท่าไหร่เอ้ยให้นักเรียนคิด
เรียนคิดว่าครูเอ๋เอ๋เกิดเดือนที่เท่า
ไหร่อ๋อเดี๋ยวนักเรียนดูคู๋มีของอะไรแล้ว
คิดครูเอกเกิดเจอเท่าไหร่ดีกว่าค่ะฟิล์ม
ไม่บอกเนื้อหาๆขอบคุณ
จริงผู้หญิงคลิปบี 0 นะเราพูดแล้วนะ
ไม่เป็นไรนักเรียนลืมแล้วค่ะ
นักเรียนคะเดี๋ยววันนี้นะคะผู้หญิงชอบ
แล้วก็เดือนที่เราเกิด
อีกคุณแม่นะคะอะที่เมื่อกี้บอกคุณแม่
คุณแม่ท้อง
รักท้องแล้วก็คลอดครูหญิงค่ะ
หญิงนะเดือนที่ 3 เดือนมีนาคมนะคะที่นี้
เนี่ยผู้หญิงนะคะผู้หญิงก็จะชอบชอบเรา
เรียกว่า
สวยๆไหมเลยสวยๆเราเรียกว่าพลอยเนาะใช่ค่ะ
พลอยสั้นๆลอยมีแต่ว่ายาวอัญมณีพลอยค่ะ
สั้นๆสั้นๆนะพลอยนะอันยังไม่ดีไม่เอาไม่
เอาไม่เอาอยากอยากเอาแต่บ้านอ่านไม่ใช่
พลอยอ้าวหรองั้นเอาอัญมณีก็ได้ค่ะพลอย
อัญมณีโอเคนะคะอ่าคุยกับเอ๋พลอยหรือ
อัญมณีกับเดือนที่เราเกิดเหรอคะให้นะคะ
12 เดือนไม่เหมือนกันไม่เหมือนกันไซส์
อะไรแล้วดีใช่ไหมคะโอ๋
โอเคไก่อะไรดีโอเคๆดียังไงไม่บอกใครค่ะ
แล้วดีมาหาอ้ายโอเคค่ะนักเรียนบอกเช่น
แล้วครูเนื้อหลุดอย่างนี้ 4 เดือนที่ 1
นะคะเดือนอะไรนะคะผู้หญิงเดือน
มกราคมเดือนมกราคมเรามีพลอยสีแดง
น้อยสีแดงอะนิดชื่ออะไรนะคะครูแอบพูดอีก 1
ครั้งชิโกลด์แมน
พูดชื่อพลอยเพราะพลอยชื่อ
โกแมนค่ะขอโอเมนอ้ะสีแดงคุณกูเอมี่เอมมี่
เอมมี่เหรอคะ
มีดีไหมดีค่ะอยากดูคือครูเอ๋น่ะชอบสอน
พลอยกูเอกก็เลยต้องซื้อลอยค่ะเก๋มีพลอย
โกเมน
ไม่พลอยโกเมนเล็กๆ
คุยทำอย่างนี้แหละพี่เอ๋มี
หู
เห้ย f สีแดงเหมือนในรูปเลย
Hi สีแดงอันนี้โกเมนราคาถ้า 2 ใส
จริงสีถ้ามีสีดำจะเห็นชัดกว่า
ครูเอ๋บีบีออ
ไม่เห็นทักอะไรเห็นเห็นสีแดงแล้วโอเคเห็น
สีแดงแล้วนะคะอันนี้ก็ Man ค่ะกูหญิง
เดือนที่ 1 เดือนมกราคมต้องใส่จี้
ตุ้มหู
แหวน
เป็น
โกแมนกรมอ๋อดีใช่ไหมถ้านักเรียนเกิดเดือน
มกราคม
ก็ใส่โกเมนดีๆค่ะทาวน์เฮ้าส์ต่อไปอยากรู้
เดือนที่ 2 แล้วค่ะเดือนที่สองชื่อเดือน
อะไรคะครูหญิงเดือนที่สองชื่อเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์โอเคเดี๋ยวคุยเลื่อนอันนี้ก่อน
นะคะได้ค่ะเดือนที่ 2 เดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ชัยค่ะ
โทษอุ้ย
เดือนกุมภาพันธ์นะคะผู้หญิงมองเห็นไหมคะ
มองเห็นค่ะค่ะเห็นสีม่วงเห็นอัญมณีสีม่วง
ค่ะนี่คืออะไรคะ
อัญมณีสีม่วงหรือพลอยสีม่วงชื่อ
อะเมทีสเอา
อะเมธี
สวยหรูเก๋ชอบอะเมธีสาคะเอกชอบอะเมทีส
ผู้เรียนมีอาจจะเกิดเดือนที่ 2 ก็ได้
โกเมนคู๋ไม่ชอบน้อง
ทำไมครูเอ๋ชอบอะเมทีสเอกชอบสีม่วงแว่น
เติมสีโม้
กระเป๋าก็สีม่วงใช่ค่ะ
เอกชอบสีม่วงอ่อนอเมทิสเนี่ยสี่ม่วงค่ะ
สำหรับเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
แล้วครูเอ๋เอ๋มีอะเมทีสไหมคะ
ไม่มีไม่มี
โอเคนะเดี๋ยววันเกิดให้สามีซื้อให้ไม่ใช่
ผู้หญิง
ตัวเองคิดผู้หญิงเดี๋ยวพูดผู้หญิงซื้อให้
ครูเอ๋ผู้หญิงไม่รู้อะเมทีสแพงไหม
และ GE บาทร้อย
อเมทิสมั้ยแพงจริงๆ 1,000 บาทก็ซื้อได้
แล้วโอเคโอเคค่ะเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงซื้อให้มา
เกิดไม่สวย 1,000 บาทน่ะอ้าว
สวยนะฮะอาจจะ 5,000 บาทครูโอ๋ๆแพงๆแข็งๆ
สวยมากๆก็แพงๆครูเอ๋ยังไม่มีค่ะค่ะเมธี
ค่ะคุณผู้หญิงขี้อะเมทีสไหมคะไงมีค่ะไม่
มีผู้หญิงมีโกเมนไหมคะใหญ่มีค่า
นักเรียนมีโกเมนไหมคะนักเรียนมีไหมเม้นท์
คำเป็น
นักเรียนมีอเมทิสไหมคะรถซ่อมเม้นท์ผู้
หญิงแต่นักเรียนเราผู้ชายมากๆๆ
ถ้าผ่านจ๊ะซื้อให้แฟนไงซื้อได้ขี่
อ่ะต่อไปต่อไป
เดือนที่ 3 ค่ะ
เด็กผู้หญิงเกิดเดือนที่ 3 นะคะศาสตร์สา
มารถแป๊บนึงนะคะยายเขมรต้องเปลี่ยนสี
ฟอนต์ใช่ไหมคะใช่
เดือนที่ 3 นะคะเดือนอะไรคะผู้หญิงเดือน
มีนาคมเดือนมีนาคมผู้หญิงเห็นพลอยไหมคะ
เป็นมีค่าเพราะ
ครูเอ๋ 2 อย่างไม่เหมือนกันเหรอคะอ่ะชื่อ
เหมือนกัน
8 แต่ว่าเกรดมั้ยเหมือนแพงไม่เหมือนกัน
ชื่ออะไรเนื้อหาอัญมณีหรือพลอยอันนี้ชื่อ
อะความารีน
เป็นสีอะไรคะผู้หญิงสีฟ้าค่ะเป็นสีฟ้า
ทะเลฮัลโหลเป็นสีฟ้าของทะเล
อายกูเอกจะมีไหมสีฟ้าทะเลน่ะน่าจะคุยหา
ก่อนนะคะนักเรียน
ได้ค่ะคุณเอ๋จะประมาณนั้นเนาะประมาณนี้
ไหม
น้ำทะเล
เข้า
เอาว่าชื่ออะความารีน
สีน้ำทะเลนะคะถ้าครูเอ๋มีไหมคะเมื่อก่อน
ครูเอ๋มีเอาความมะรีนเอ้าแล้วไปไหน
ไม่รู้เป็นไรครูหญิงนี่ธจะมีเหรอคะอ่ะอ่า
r&a Stop สกรีนอันนี้นะจะได้เห็นเอา
ความ Marine ใหญ่ๆๆๆเห็นแล้วเอกก็กดนะ
ครับผู้หญิงไม่เคยเช็ดมาเลย 2 อันไม่คุย
คุยอะไรคะ
อันนี้อะความารีนนิอันเนี่ยความ Marine
นี้นะคะสีครีมขอกูเอกให้ผู้หญิงไม่รู้อัน
ไหนเป็นอะไรนะคะ
ทำไมคู่หญิงไม่แท้
แพงไม่ได้ใส่นานมาก
นักเรียนอันนี้ของครูเอ๋ทำไมอยู่ที่ครู
หญิงค่ะเราก็ครูหญิงเกิดเดือนมีนาคม
อัญมณีของครูหญิงก็คืออะความารีนครูหญิง
ใส่แล้วดีดีครูเอกก็เลยให้
สงสารเคยชายค่ะแต่ก็ไม่เคยใส่นะคะนั้นก็
เรียน
มากครูหญิงโทษมากเหมือนกัน
ผู้หญิงห้ามหายนะหายไวได้ใช่ผู้หญิงก็เลย
เก็บนะคะเก็บ
นี่กล่องเป็นอัญมณีที่ครูเอกซื้อแล้วก็
แพงที่สุดนี้ชีวิตเอ๋บอกได้ไหมคะเท่าไหร่
ทั้งหมดประมาณ
15,000 บาทกู
เพลงอ่ะทั้งจี้แล้วก็สร้อยๆ
10,000
5000 บาท 5,000 บาทนะคะ
มันสวยเนาะก็เป็นสีฟ้าเนาะไม่รักเธอไป
2,000 บาทหรอผมขอ
ไม่เรียนครูเอกซื้อใหม่แพงนะคะไม่เเพง
โกลด์แมนน่ะโกเมนอ่ะอ่าจริงๆโกเมน
โกเมนเท่าไหร่นะ
ก็แมนสิ 400 บาทค่ะอันนี้เพชรอ่ะเป็นไม่
ใช่เพชรจริงๆนะคะเป็นอ่าชีวิตที่คนเนี่ยม
เราอันนี้ฟรี
ส่วนเซ็ตนี้เสร็จนี้
2,000 บาทอ่ะเอา
2,000  400 บาทค่ะไม่แพงนะเขา
ขอบความมาได้ยินแพงคุยใช้กลิ่นต้องเก็บกู
เองว่าเอาคืนผู้หญิงล้างนะร้านยังไม่เป็น
ตัวเอง
กูเองต้องสอนและเป็นต้องมีวีดีโอ 1 สอน
ล้าง and  you จะมี
ฟันลัยอ่ะโอเค
ครูเอ๋เอ๋อยากรู้เดือนต่อไปแล้วค่ะเดือน
ต่อไปเดือนที่ 4 เดือนที่ 4 นะคะเดือนที่
4 มามั้ยอะแล้วมองเห็นชัดไหมถ้าเห็นไม่
ชัดต้องลงสีดำ
นี่คุยลงตอนนี้เลยนะคะได้ค่ะเอา
background เป็นสีดำหนู
เดือนที่ 4 นะคะ
เดือนที่สี่อ้าว
เกดต้องเปลี่ยนสีฟอนต์
โอเค
ต้องเอาเค้กลงค่ะผู้หญิง
เดือนที่
เอ้าคุยจะพิมพ์ได้ไหม
เดือนที่ 4 เดือนอะไรเดือน
ฮะโอเคเขียนเลยแล้วกันค่ะเรื่อง
เร็วกว่าบอกนะเขียนได้มั้ยเนี่ย
ไม่ให้กูอีกเขียนอ่ะ
อ้าวเดือนที่ 4 เดือนอะไรคะครูหญิงเดือน
เมษายนเดือนเมษายน
ค่ะเมษายน
ผู้หญิงที่เกิดเดือนเมษายน
โต๊ะแล้วอัญมณีอะไรคะ
เพชรค่ะโอ้ยผู้หญิงทำไมไม่เกิดเดือน
เมษายน
แพงค่ะใช่ค่ะนี่ก็ได้มีเพจ
ไม่โอเคแต่
โอ้โอ้ะคุณพ่อคุณแม่ซื้อให้ไม่ได้
น้าน้าาไปซื้อใครไม่ได้
Copy โอเคมั้ยโอเคค่ะผู้หญิงไว้เข้าใจ
เพชรจริงเพชรปลอมอันนี้คิวเบ็ดเสร็จคอ
เนี่ยค่ะคิวเบ็ดเสร็จคนนี้แล้วรู้เอกครู
เอ๋
ครูเองมีเพชรไหมคะไม่ใช่อันนั้น
โอ้วเย้
คู๋เป็นครู
นี่
ไงเห็นไหมครูเอ๋แต่งงานแล้วต้องมีแหวน
เพชรนี่ไม่ใช่แหวนเพชรอ้าว
มีเล็กๆเขาจะมองเห็นไหม
หนอเห็นไหมคะหรือว่าต้อง
โอเคไม่เป็นไรหรอกอ่ะโอเคไม่เห็นไม่เห็น
น่ะ
อ๋อโอ้ยเห็นแล้วค่ะอ๋อเล็กๆเล็กๆตัวเล็กๆ
แล้วก็ไม่ได้ล้างเหมือนคุณ
เอ้าวันนี้แขวนครูเอ๋ใส่ที่นิ้วนางข้าง
ซ้ายทุกวันข้างใน
ไม่มีแหวนเพชรจริงๆแต่มีหาเพชรเล็กๆอยู่
ด้วยนะคะ
มากๆๆค่ะเพราะว่าเพชรแท้แรงมากๆไงเดี๋ยว
ครูหญิงคู๋ทำงานเป็นครู
5 ปีรถซื้อเมียจะไม่ได้ค่ะ
เงินใบพอผู้หญิงอันนี้อันนี้ก็อ่ะ
1,000 บาทซื้อได้โอเคนะไม่เป็นไร
ถ้าคัดเกรดเกรด A ก็ 30,000 บาท
ตอนเกรด A ของอ่ะจะสบายของคิวบิดอะไร
เนี่ยค่ะ Unit ใส่คนนี้อยู่พิเศษโคเนียม
แต่ก็สวยนะรูหญิงดูสวย
ครูเอ๋ค่ะก็ดูสวยได้อ่ะต่อไปต่อไปนะคะต่อ
ไปเดือนที่ 5 ค่ะเดือนที่ 5 ราคาเดือนที่
หาย
ผู้หญิงเห็นไหมคะเห็นค่าหน้าเนี่ย
เดือนที่ห้าลบ
ทำไมอ่ะ
เดือนที่ห้าเดือนอะไรคะเรียน
พฤษภาคมเดือน
พฤษภาคมค่ะสู้
อัญมณีของคนที่เกิดเดือนที่ 5 เรียกว่า
อะไรคะสีเขียวๆสีเขียวใช่ไหมอ่ะอาเฮียย้ง
มี 2 อย่างค่ะอ๋อมีอะไรบ้างคะครูเอ๋มี
มรกตค่ะอันนี้
ของกินก็ว่ามันกินเขียวไม่เหมือนกัน
อันนี้น่ะชื่อ
มรกตอ๋ออ๋อแล้วอีก 2 อันนี่ชื่อเหมือนกัน
ใช่ไหมคะ
2 อันนี้หยกค่ะค่ะ
ครูเอ๋มีไหมคะมรกตแล้วก็หยกแหวน
ผู้หญิงดูแล้วเห็นแกเดินไม่คุยรู้อยู่
แล้วนี่เนาะ
whoami แหวนมรกต
เว่ย
สวยนะคะคู่เอ๋แจง
[เพลง]
มีผู้หญิงชอบสีเขียวมากกว่าสีม่วงค่ะ
แล้วครูเอกก็มีมีอะไรอีกแล้วก็มีจี้
เป็นมรกตใช่ไหมคะที่มรกตนะคะ
มีหมดหรือยังคะ
มรกตนะคะหมดแล้วเอาแล้ว
เอาไป Copy  10 ครูเอ๋มีหยกไหมคะถอด
จะมีอยู่ที่คอกูเสียด้วยกันเลยนะ D
Double
อันนี้เป็นพระเป็น
เป็นหยกรหัส
กวนอิมเป็นไชนิสคอสใช่ไหมคะคุณเองให้
กวนอิมชื่อกวนอิมทำจากหยกนะคะนี่แล้วคู่
เอกก็มีอีกค่ะกูหญิงหยกมีมีอะไรคะปูเอ๋มี
ลิง
ลิงลิงเป็นหยกโห
ยังไม่ได้แกะเลยเอาหยกที่เป็นแกะเป็นรูป
ลิงลิงเก๋ๆจุ๊บๆๆๆเหมือนไหม
ดูไม่ค่อยเข้าจะไปสว่าง
แต่ว่าเป็นลิงเดี๋ยวพี่หารูปลิงก็ได้ค่ะ
กูเองคู๋ต้องให้ดูแบบนี้ถึงจะเข้าใจ
เหมือนมั้ยนักเรียนลิงปิดไฟแล้วกันนะคะ
ปวด
นั่นลิงอานี่นะลิงนะคะนักเรียน
โอเคเปิดไฟค่ะแล้วครูเอกก็มีอีกผู้หญิง
แพ้นี่อกอีกหรอคะมีหยกเป็นปลา
ค่ะน้อง
มีปลา
จริงๆทั้งหมดฟรีนะคะค่ะแล้วคุยก็มีหยก
เป็นแบบนี้ด้วยอ๋อเป็นวงกลมเป็นจี้ใช่ไหม
GT สร้อยคอๆแล้วครูเอกก็ไม่
รู้เหตุไม่มีหยกยอดมากเก๋มีหยกเยอะมากๆ
ไหมเอาทำอะไรอ่ะไม่รู้
เป็นอะไรอีก
อยากได้อันนี้หรออันนี้อันนี้อายุอายุมาก
กว่าครูเอ๋นะคะค่ะวันนี้มันใหญ่อ่ะกูเอง
อันนี้อายุ
มากกว่า 54 ปีหนู
2 อันนี้อายุประมาณประมาณ 60 ปี
[เพลง]
60 ปีแล้วค่ะนี้
10 ปีเต็มที่แล้วค่ะหนูนานฟรี
ขอ
เพลงผู้หญิงรู้บ้านครูเอ๋อยู่ไหนอยู่ที่
ไหนคะโอ้โหคดี Online
A มีหยกมากๆนะคะง่าเครย์ได้อีก 1 เดือน
อ่ะหมดเวลาเหรอคะ
ใช่สิหมดเวลา
[เพลง]
โอ้ยอีก 1 เดือนเดือนที่ 6 หน้าเดือนที่
ครบคุยน่าจะอร่อยนะตกผู้หญิงห้ามกินโอเค
เดือนที่ 6 นะคะเดือนอะไรคะผู้หญิงเรียน
ที่ 6 เดือนมิถุนายน
เดือนที่ 6 นะคะอ่ะอ่ะ
เสื้อ
สีขาวตัวเอง
เหมือนที่ 6x เขียนแล้วกันค่ะเดือนที่ 6
เดือนมิ.ย.ค่ะเดือนมิถุนายนแล้วอัญมณีของ
คนที่เกิดเดือนมิถุนายนคืออะไรคะไข่มุก
ค่ะโหสองรูปเนี่ยเป็นไข่มุกเหรอคะคู๋ I
ค่ะอันนี้เนี่ยเป็นไข่มุกเอามาทำสร้อยค่ะ
แล้วก็อันนี้เป็นไข่มุกที่ยังอยู่ในหอย
มุกหูใส่มุกมาจากหอยใช่มาจากถอยมุกอ๋อผู้
หญิงคุยชอบมากทำไมผู้หญิงไม่ชอบ
เอกชอบแต่ไม่มีเฮเอ้ามันจะถามเลย
พี่เก๋มีไข่มุกมั้ยมีมีมีมีแบบนี้ไม่ใช่
ไข่มุกไม่รู้จริงเหรอตรงนี้ใช่ไข่มุกที่
มาจากหอยมุกแบบแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะกับไม่รู้
เนอะเออ
150 บาท
อาจจะเป็นมุกฟาร์มไหมคะมุกห้องแล็บนกอัน
นี้ก็มุกฟาร์มแต่อันนี้อะหรอมุกมุกอะไรนะ
มุกพลาสติก
150 บาท
150 บาทไม่ใช่มุกค่ะไว้ใจมุกค่ะโอ้งั้น
ไข่มุกแพงแห้งๆไข่มุกจริงๆก็แพงนะหวยมุก
ทะเลอะมุกทะเลจะแข่งอายแม่น้ำไม่แพง
ไข่มุกแม่น้ำก็มีๆขอมุกสีดำแบบเนี้ยโอ้โห
แพง
หือเดือนมิถุนายนต้องใส่มุกแพงแล้วก็หาย
แล้ว
ฉีดน้ำหอมไม่ได้
ทำไมคะมุกจะไม่สวยมุกจะ
[เพลง]
ก็เราก็ได้นะเพราะเราไม่ฉีดน้ำหอมให้
สร้างครูเอ๋นะเห็นมุกและเอกชอบไข่มัดครู
เอ๋ชอบครั้งหมดค่ะ
มีแค่ 6 เดือนเองนั่นแหละเหตุเดือนครูเอ๋
ชอบไม่ชอบโกเมนไม่ชอบหนึ่งนะคะ
เวลาแล้ว High ค่ะคิดว่าต้องนักเรียนต้อง
รอดูวีดีโอต่อไปได้ค่ายงั้นคลิปมาให้ก่อน
แล้วต่อคลิปหน้านะคะนักเรียนมาดูถ้าเกิด
เดือนอะไรใส่อัญมณีอะไรดีปี่ไปค่ะแต่ว่า
วันนี้ก็ไปแล้วเนาะสวัสดีค่ะถ้าบ๊ายบาย